i'm not the man you remember you're
going to have to be obi-wan kenobi is
back and his return has shaken the
universe join us as we check out how
everyone's been handling the craziness
on set
[Laughter]
and
number one is that obi-wan no it kenobi
where's he been it was a surreal
experience for hayden christensen to see
you and mcgregor on set but honestly no
one was more excited than i was personal
connection aside the crew was filled
with cinephiles so we'd say his
excitement was on par there were a lot
of star wars fans uh that were part of
our crew
so they all had their geek out moments
when the actors showed up in costume
this was pretty exciting for ewin who
for years felt icky about the prequels
after they were trashed by critics ewin
said it was a very long slow process of
coming back to playing him at the end of
every interview i was asked two things
would i do the sequel to trainspotting
and would i ever play obi-wan kenobi
again ewen was skeptical but he came to
learn that the generation who grew up on
the prequels loved them but now you feel
that warmth from the fans
after many years and it's really nice so
when he learned this it really
rejuvenated him reversing those bitter
feelings he continued then disney just
asked me to come in one day for a
meeting because they kept seeing on
social media that i would like to play
obi-wan kenobi again if i could be part
of that then i would want to do that
number two this new tech is the
innovation actors have been waiting a
lifetime for the green and blue screens
are the way of the past you know we have
these amazing huge lcd screen dome that
goes around the stage the technology of
the future is called stagecraft so if
we're playing a scene in the desert well
it's the desert everywhere you look ewen
said if you're flying through space then
the stars are flying past you as you
scout along it's so cool just a much
more visceral experience number three to
fight in a movie training must you do
their teacher probably wasn't yoda if
you don't count the stunt doubles the
jedi school was pretty empty and one
student moses ingram was just a bit of a
bad apple getting in a ton of trouble
from her manager for posting this video
she got to keep her lightsaber handle
from the shoot these new lightsabers are
a step up from the ones that were used
for the prequels which were just metal
blades closer to real swords than
anything and at the speed they were
fighting talk about dangerous rupert
friend said of his character the grand
inquisitors fight scenes there is a
smooth silent deadly efficiency to
everything it's not two guys brawling in
a bar these are master master swordsmen
masters of pretty much all the martial
arts you could imagine rolled into one
they handed it to me and it's this
double-ended yeah heavy
spinning badass thing number four this
one's juicy rupert friend spent four
hours in the makeup chair starting at
3am with three people doing his
prosthetics you know all these pieces of
stuff on and contact lenses in and teeth
in and then earmuffs so it's kind of
like sensory deprivation at times his
armor weighed about 45 pounds and would
make him sweat profusely he avoided
watching rebels fully aware that the
character appeared in the animated show
he said i really wanted to honor the
character as i saw him and so i almost
deliberately did not see the animated
interpretation
it feels like
being invited to the greatest party that
you
hadn't ever really imagined
was going on he also observed that the
character has this very juicy way of
enjoying himself saying and i just
thought what does the guy who enjoys the
sound of his own voice sound like you
know who we are
and that's what we got juicy do you know
the key to hunting jedi friend
number five we've barely got the hang of
this one in video games let alone real
life moses ingram got to run across
walls she said it's hard to picture but
it was fly and once she even got to
cross the wall without being supported
by wires that mustn't have gone too well
if after that she got wired up ingram
said it was really fun it's fun to be
bad the weaponry and the stunt work once
you get to a point where your body is
confident doing the moves that plays
into it as well as the costumes but i
can say that there are a lot of crazy
crazy cool moments in this thing number
six only amateurs would drop a
lightsaber obi-wan would always sass
anakin if he dropped his lightsaber or
misplaced it in the movies and that kind
of you know narrative continued offset
too but then karma happened no i think i
dropped it and i i said to moses don't
tell hayden number seven returning to an
old character is like discovering math
homework from grade 12. hayden
christensen had to have a vader movement
specialist come in and make sure his
every motion was authentic to the
character ewan mcgregor struggled to
relearn his voice for the character he
went back and watched all the movies to
help him i totally didn't have his voice
at all he disappointed the entire crew
when he was so rusty at it he rectified
that though saying so i went back and
did some homework with alec guinness and
what he'd done before in the original
films i'm looking for a jedi
number eight if they didn't auction off
the original costumes they could have
just pulled them out of storage the
darth vader suit is improved every time
the character returns to the screen ewan
loved being able to act with the
stormtroopers in this
that's a long story it's a long way
because they didn't exist yet in the
prequels moses ingram said the costume
designer did such an amazing job of
building something that when you step
into it it lends itself to a feeling
when she got involved her costume had
already been designed but her hair was
imagined to be completely different than
it ended up being on screen and it was
not something ingram's hair does
naturally so ingram told the director
and together they came up with the
braids instead
maybe you've been looking in the wrong
places
number nine deborah went hans solo for
this one debra chow directed every
single episode of the show that isn't
always the case with tv shows and
certainly wasn't the case for the
mandalorian it would have been different
i think if we'd had a different director
for each episode she was there for all
of the nuanced moments and character
development and that's the advantage of
directing an entire show yourself her
biggest challenge was that the story
came between episodes three and four the
audience knowing where the characters
were coming from and ultimately where
they would end up really limited their
options i really don't think i could
have honestly done kenobi if i hadn't
done mandalorian first deborah was so
excited to work on really
character-driven stories in the new
obi-wan kenobi show just you have the
opportunity obviously to take the vision
right from the very beginning all the
way to the end number 10 you should just
expect people who run along walls to
drive ridiculously moses isn't a huge
fan of driving slow so she cut off the
motorcycle in front of her on her way to
work when i see a yellow light it means
green but like lighter then the
motorcycle pulled into the same lot as
her and the person takes off their
helmet and is human this isn't the first
time this has happened to her either
that honor went to denzel washington
number 11. ask the ogs ewen and hayden
got to have input on where their
characters were going ewan didn't work
with the writers but he was constantly
giving his thoughts and opinions on the
script their instincts are always
correct if anyone was ever unsure about
a line of dialogue they would go right
to the actors because who'd worked with
these characters the longest that's
right the actors
we'll see
take her to interrogation
number 12. show don't tell is a
filmmaker's number one rule deborah chao
always goes back to westerns and samurai
films for her references writer joby
harold said i'm very aware of how potent
the imagery can be in star wars and
slowing everything down so that that
imagery can have as much weight as
possible was the goal throughout
especially when it was going to help
articulate obi-wan's arc this is why the
lightsaber on his hip was the closing
image of the first episode it's why he
holds the lightsaber at the end of
episode 2 and doesn't use it so that
when he does use it it means something
that's also why he uses the force for
the first time in a long time when he
saves leia harold said all of those
choices are very deliberate
architecturally so that they're hand in
hand with the lead character as he's
arcing rhythmically
number 13. there will never be another
grogo disney joby herald talked about
the importance of including a young
princess leia harold wanted to make
connections to existing characters that
he could embellish so to include a young
princess leia was important he said it
answers the question of why him so help
me obi-wan kenobi you're my only hope
feels less arbitrary as a choice and a
decision now that we know the depth of
the history they have together given she
named her son after ben kenobi it made
sense to deepen that bond through the
new show the whole time i've known you
you've been hiding something
number 14 star wars is for everybody
moses ingram helped create the look and
feel of her character she wanted to
inspire young girls who also want to
dress up as star wars characters she
remembers growing up and watching
certain things with her brothers and
being told that this stuff was for boys
saying what's cool about this is you can
fight like a girl and still be badass
which is pretty cool she gives a lot of
credit to the director deborah chao for
welcoming her in and caring about her
thoughts in terms of who the third
sister might be nobody is looking for me
to be something specific and i sort of
have free reign to be who i think riva
is number 15. ewin is like cheese he
looks better with age ew and mcgregor
had to do a ton of fitness training
because the fight sequences are really
hard to do and can take weeks to shoot
now being in his 50s ewin had to get
super fit before they started just to
keep up while star wars fans still can't
agree on whether any material following
the originals is good or not there's one
thing we can agree on we missed you
obi-wan kenobi how did you get into
watching star wars let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things